what's up guys welcome to another stock
indicators and mathematics within python
tutorial video last video we were
calculating the center of gravity now
it's actually plotted up on that chart
if you don't have the data for the chart
the link is in the description that will
take you to this page here
if you scroll down this is where the
code is so literally just highlight it
all come all the way down the bottom do
a nice copy and paste it right in
now i did make a little spot for us to
put all the code which will be right
here so all you have to really do at
this point is go back to where we were
coding the script just now and go ahead
and comment out cog or delete that one
right there
and then all you want to do is just
highlight the definition of call go all
the way down to the bottom even where it
calls
to cog to run
take that go over to the new script
paste it in and then fix the indentation
so we'll go back up
and it should be indent indent which is
just hitting the tab key in case you
didn't know
um
so now
we've done that we call cog uh here and
all we really need to do to put it into
the graph
is the following so we're just going to
go ahead and say
cog dates
and then we'll just say
cogs
equals
that
then all we really need to do from here
is x2 dot plot
and we plot cog dates and then minus sp
that's just the starting point if you
want to know more about that watch uh
the actual charting tutorial series uh
you can find that in my channel
uh cogs
minus sp colon
and then finally we're gonna make that
line uh white
so that should be it we should be able
to run that now and get uh the center of
gravity so let's plot up ebay and just
see that we got it
okay so sure enough here's ebay uh with
the center of gravity i'm trying to
think of another stock that we could do
i just love how like well it called it
there i mean there was not too much here
um
yeah it's been high i suppose and now
it's slumping down but try to think of a
good one to run here um
let's try ford we haven't actually
looked at ford in any of the videos
yeah ford did pretty good too in the
center here um
as far as predicting that uptrend pretty
nice
anyway uh so that's going to conclude
the center of gravity tutorial series
hopefully you guys enjoyed hopefully you
learned something as always thanks for
watching thanks for the support and
subscriptions and until next time